Gabrielle...
Je vais te donner la possibilité de comprendre à 100% une personne qui compte.
Donc en fait, tu peux lire du texte sous moi, quoi...
C'est ouf !
Si je mets du blanc, ça dit quoi ?
On s'en fout de ça.
Salut Gabrielle.
Moi je vois très bien ce qu'il voulait dire avec son petit ton là : "Oui bon je te baiserai bien une fois..."
"T'es passable mais pas plus."
C'est le sourire de coincé du cul que tu fais quand tu es mal à l'aise !
Parce que je mets mal à l'aise.
Je pense qu'il y a ton mec qui t'attends là-bas. Mon mec ?!
Vous, vraiment, vous avez de la chance. Au moins, vous vous dîtes la vérité.
Je t'aime, Julien.
Bah moi aussi, je t'aime.
Bon, heu... Moi, j'y vais parce que je suis à la bourre.
Docteur Pirogue !
Faut m'enlever les machins que vous m'avez mis là, j'en veux pas.
On se calme, hein !
Je suis chez moi, aussi, hein !
T'emménages avec Louise ?
Pourquoi tu me l'as pas dit ?
Bah j'ai pas eu l'occasion.
T'aimes bien ?
C'est bien, ça !